every year
hurricanes batter the north atlantic and
affect
millions of people the damage can be
catastrophic
and these storms are getting worse
but what if we had a way to stop
these ferocious storms
what creates a hurricane
what is a salter sink
and why could thousands of wind turbines
save lives this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we could control
hurricanes hurricanes
can only form when the ocean's surface
is warm
and every decade the surface temperature
of the seas
have been increasing by 0.13 degrees
by the year 2100 the mean global ocean
temperature
could increase up to 4 degrees
this means we'll have more severe
hurricanes
with higher wind speeds more
precipitation
and more human casualties thankfully
scientists are looking at ways to stop
these vicious storms
using geoengineering the large-scale
manipulation
of the earth's environment but
how could we do that to control
hurricanes
we need to find a way to control ocean
temperatures first
hurricanes form when the water is at
least
26.5 degrees and there's a weather
disturbance like
a thunderstorm as a thunderstorm moves
across the ocean it sucks in the warm
surface
air as the warm air rises
colder air rushes in to fill the space
this is what causes the ferocious winds
of a hurricane
the air movement turns into a cycle as
the ocean
heats up the cooler air the storm will
continue
as long as the ocean is warm and water
can evaporate from the surface
to stop this cycle we'd need to
lower the surface temperature of the
ocean
so we're going to look at three
different technologies to control
hurricanes
first we have the aerosol idea
basically we'd spray aerosols into the
sky
these aerosols would reflect some of the
sun's radiation
back into outer space the ocean would
absorb less radiation and begin to cool
it doesn't sound very complicated and
advanced computer simulations
showed that spring aerosols above the
northern hemisphere would
tame hurricanes in the atlantic ocean
sounds great what are we waiting for
well it turns out that spring aerosols
above the southern hemisphere
made hurricanes more severe in the north
atlantic
the altered weather also increased the
drought
in africa's sahel region
[Music]
okay maybe using aerosols isn't such a
cool idea
let's move on to the salter sink
these are wave powered pumps that would
cool the surface water of an ocean
by mixing warm and cool water
imagine thousands of big rings bobbing
up and down in the atlantic
waves would push the warmer surface
water into the top of the cylinder
then pump it down a funnel-like tube
into the colder water
about 100 meters below the salter sinks
would be located in hurricane alley
where the worst
storms usually develop we'd need to use
150 to
450 of them to weaken hurricanes
the third idea is to use a fleet of
unmanned ships to spray ocean water into
the air
these tiny salt water droplets would
form
bright clouds over the ocean
how would that cool the ocean's surface
well instead of sunlight hitting the
ocean and being absorbed
the sunlight would hit bright clouds and
be reflected back into space
all of these ideas would take
maintenance and
monitoring and they're not all
guaranteed to work as planned
geoengineering weather systems is
challenging and
it could have dangerous side effects but
if geoengineering is too risky
are there other ways to weaken
hurricanes
[Music]
you know controlling hurricanes may be
difficult but controlling your business
shouldn't be you need to stay quick and
nimble so why are you still using
quickbooks and spreadsheets it's time to
upgrade to netsuite
stop paying for multiple systems that
don't give you the crucial information
you need
when you need it be prepared for future
storms
by upgrading today to netsuite by oracle
the world's number one cloud business
system no matter the weather
netsuite gives you visibility and
control over your financials
hr inventory e-commerce and more
all in one place and instantaneously it
doesn't matter if you're doing
a million or hundreds of millions in
revenue save
time and money with netsuite join the
over 24 000 companies using netsuite
right now
let netsuite show you how they'll
benefit your business with a free
product tour
at netsuite.com what if seriously
schedule your free product tour right
now at netsweep.com
what if and in case you didn't hear me
over this wind
that's netsweep.com what if
well instead of controlling hurricanes
why not use their strength to help us
we could build offshore wind farms along
coastlines
the turbines spinning blades would act
as a buffer
and make the hurricanes dissipate faster
and
that's a big deal using
a computer simulation one study found
that
if there had been a wind farm in front
of new orleans during
hurricane katrina the peak wind speed
could have been reduced
by 145 kilometers per hour
and the storm surge could have been
reduced by almost 80 percent
that would have saved a lot of homes and
lives
but we'd need about 78 000
wind farms to curb the impact of a
katrina-sized storm
so maybe we should focus on other ways
to reduce the ocean's temperature
like reducing the amount of carbon
dioxide we emit
switching to green energy or even
painting the earth white
yeah you heard me right painting the
earth white
could help fight climate change
but that's the story for another
what if
you